- [Narrator] The planet we live on is full
of life and has been
for billions of years.
Living things on earth
have existed for as long
as they have, because life
found a way to create life.
Sounds crazy, right?
To put it another way,
living things found ways to reproduce,
creating offspring that can then go on
to reproduce themselves,
but what exactly is reproduction?
Well, reproduction is the
process of making new organisms.
This happens when parent
organisms reproduce
to form offspring.
During reproduction,
organisms pass their genetic information
on to their offspring.
This genetic information
provides blueprints
for how the offspring
will grow and develop
and it's how traits get
passed on from one generation
to the next.
There are two main ways
organisms on earth reproduce.
This is through asexual
reproduction or sexual reproduction.
Let's start off by breaking
down asexual reproduction first.
In asexual reproduction,
only one parent is involved
in producing offspring.
Due to this, the
offspring will inherit all
of their genes from that single parent.
This means that asexual
reproduction produces offspring
that are genetically
identical to their parent,
or in other words, they have
the same collection of genes.
Various kinds of microorganisms, plants,
and even animals are able
to reproduce asexually.
An example of asexual reproduction
in microorganisms can be seen in bacteria.
This is due to their
use of a specific type
of asexual reproduction
called binary fission.
During this process,
a single bacteria cell
grows, copies its genes,
and divides into two identical cells,
kind of like a copy machine.
Plants are able to
reproduce asexually too.
For example, some plants
grow their offspring off
of themselves.
In fact, in many succulents,
you can see baby plants growing
off of their parent plant.
These babies have the same
genes as their parent plant
and can grow on their own
if you remove them and plant them in soil.
Finally, and interestingly,
there are various animals
that can reproduce asexually.
One example is seen in
starfish or sea stars.
Some species of starfish can split
into multiple parts that
then grow into new starfish
and, since they have the same genes,
each new starfish is a
clone of its original.
Now that we've covered
asexual reproduction,
let's move on to sexual reproduction.
Unlike asexual reproduction,
sexual reproduction
involves two parents producing
an offspring together
instead of one.
This is important
because it means that the
offspring will inherit half
of their genes from one parent
and half of their genes from the other.
Because of this, a sexual
reproduction produces offspring
that are genetically distinct
or have a different combination
of genes compared to either parent.
With this, because of the
way the genes are passed on,
there are tons of different combinations
of genes that can be received
from the two parents.
In other words, this means
that sexual reproduction creates
offspring that show a lot
of genetic variation
between their siblings.
To better understand this,
let's take a look at my own dogs.
They're brother and sister,
so they share the same
parents, which I've drawn here.
As you've probably noticed,
my dogs look pretty different
from each other.
One of the most notable
differences though is how one
of them received genes from this parent
that gave them markings above their eyes
that kind of looked like
eyebrows while the other did not.
And while it's easy to
spot genetic differences,
like my dog's eyebrows,
genetic variation goes
way deeper than dog's fur.
It's what makes sexual
reproduced organisms
genetically distinct from each other
and gives the building
blocks to who they are.
And with that, you now know the difference
between asexual and sexual reproduction.
Let's do a quick overview of
what you've learned today.
Living organisms reproduce
to create offspring
through either asexual
or sexual reproduction.
Asexual reproduction
involves only one parent
meaning the parent and offspring
will have identical genes.
Sexual reproduction involves two parents
and results in offspring
that are genetically unique
compared to either
parent and this all goes
to show how fantastically unique life
on earth is.
Though organisms may differ
in the ways that they've
been able to reproduce
as seen in the examples
between bacteria, succulents,
starfish, and dogs,
these organisms, as
with all living things,
share the ability to create more life
just as all life has shared
for billions of years here on this planet.